okay so sq up what is it
sq as a solution to a problem and the
problem is we've been looking at
databases for a while now the whole idea
the whole reason you use a database is
because you've got lots and lots of data
right sometimes hundreds thousands maybe
even millions of records things that you
want to describe and lots of things that
you know about the things you want to
describe right so databases tend to be
very large now thinking about some of
the data that you use on a normal basis
like see your time table or say the
books in your bag
right that's kind of like a database of
sorts when you're looking for something
in that database you're looking for
something specific what's the way you go
about it well usually you just get it
out and you flick through it manually
right for instance you're like okay
today's Monday a what is it we go right
you think what have I got period three
so you get out your whole database and
you look through the entire thing until
you find the period you're looking for
okay this is what we're not going to go
to write or say your bag you go in and
you can sift through all of the books to
find the one that you're after because
it's not that much there right but that
that sort of method isn't going to work
for large databases if you've got
millions of Records it simply would do
to just start looking through the entire
thing right you'll be there forever okay
so SQL is one of the solutions we will
have a look at other ones they derive in
other lessons now how to solve this
problem how do I get at all this data
heaps and even heaps how do I get to it
so let's start by defining SQL and
hopefully that will explain how it's a
solution to this problem okay SQL stands
for structured query language
it's designed by IBM uh something like
forty years ago they're about I it's a
predecessor by the way was structured
English query language we made it so
international but because of where it
came from and it's old acronym it's
pronounced SQL is pronounced sequel not
um not squall squall anyway so if you if
you see that sometimes you'll see
something I'll talk about a bit later on
a particular implementation of SQL and
they pronounce that my sequel right so
anyway what is it
what's a query in normal language when
we talk about I like to query you about
something do you think of a synonym for
that query yeah question I think
something you want to ask you're posing
a question to something to try and get
to information outright that's the same
ID here this is not just any question
though it's a it's a structured question
right
hence structured query and language just
means there's a set of defined rules
that show how this works okay so that's
what SQL means let me show you what one
query in structured query language
actually looks like okay so a query in
SQL has four components okay and you'll
see how each is important to get our
data from a database okay
so I'll put them all down and then we'll
discuss them
all right so here the fit four pieces
okay
what are we looking at we remember the
structure of a database right databases
themselves in structure that's why the
queries that deal with them are also
structured databases relational
databases are made up of tables that are
made up of records and fields right
which describe all the things in them
so select talks about okay which fields
in is really really large database you
might have hundreds of fields which
feels am i interested in okay
so for instance you might say I'm
interested in students and their marks
students and their marks
so I might say student dot name
okay now student dot name right student
means that's the table and looking at
this is the student table and name is
the particular field in the table that
I'm interested in
okay so that's why student dot name is
referring to I might have a few others
on there like maybe a student class and
so on and so on are extra things that
maybe I'll just add that
and of course if you've got a relational
database you've got lots and lots of
different tables there you can select as
be tables and fields as you like maybe
dozens and dozens and dozens whatever is
relevant to what you're looking for okay
okay now from from seems kind of
redundant if you've got these tables
here under finding what tables are
looking for you so in this case it'd
just be student ok sometimes you'll just
see name and class up here these are the
fields right whereas from says which
tables are you interested in okay now
where now this is a really important
part okay where means I'm creating you
for data out of this database I want
specific done either just want the whole
lot I want ones that meet certain
conditions okay so for instance just
recently for this presentation data
coming up next week right
wait no bit later I can't read words
coming up this rehearsal as well we have
to select who's first in subject for
every you know every every subject
that's there so I might be looking for
say the top three students of the class
or maybe the people in the class you've
got a certain mark over you know say
ninety okay so what I would do is I'd
say something like where a particular
field meets a particular condition such
as student dot total mark is greater
than ninety see what's going on I'm
looking at a particular field and I'm
applying a condition to it and so this
is the question I'm posing so obviously
not everyone in the database will meet
this condition so the output of this
query the answer to the question if you
like we'll just put give me those
particular things that will meet this
condition okay I might apply other
conditions as well I might say the
students total mark is greater than
ninety um and for instance their
students what assessments have you guys
done let's just go for the most recent
one the term for exam is greater than 85
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
looking for both of these conditions to
be met simultaneously right
I could go student Turtleback or student
ten for exam okay
so these are different logical operators
we'll look at those in a second okay
lastly I've looked at which fields I've
looked at the tables I've applied a
condition that's what we're means okay
and lastly I want some kind of order I
don't want them placed out randomly
I'm databases are really good at
ordering things right so order what kind
of sequence and I am I going to put
these in again I'll pick a field perhaps
the results I want I can put them in
order of name right I might say by
student name and then I can choose
either ascending or descending now
ascending descending how does this work
when it's numbers ascending is easy
right it's just one two three four five
six seven eight right so if it's
ascending the smallest values are at the
beginning and the largest ones at the
end right
descending would be backwards if I went
by student name and I said ascending
we're not be starting with the letter A
or why would I be starting with the
letter said hmm if it's ascending it
should be a right now how can you
remember people get these confused all
the time the letter A is the first
letter in the alphabet right so it has
the numerical numerical value one and
the letters ed of course is the last one
okay so if I'm ascending I'm going from
small to big then I'm going from A to Z
which is usually
the way that we have alphabetical lists
right so I would write a SC for
ascending if I want to descending I
would say de yes sit for just n so
there's a typical query all right that's
just one example of what it would look
like it's the whole thing all together
the black and the red parts the blue
parts are just describing what's
happening okay okay so we just did one
and two just now we define what this
language is and we describe the four
components of a typical query with that
example let's dig in a little further I
was sort of alluding to this but I
didn't go into much detail about
different operators and wildcards what
are operators and wildcards I'm going to
delete this and I'll show you what I
mean
we'll talk about operators first
operators are about logic so often these
are called logical operators and I
actually gave you an example of one
before so there are three main kinds
there's a 4.0 of give you in a second
there's actually more than that but
these are the ones the most commonly
used and B right it means I've got two
conditions for instance we were looking
at a mark being greater than something
and a different mark also being greater
than something right and means I want
them both fulfilled simultaneously that
makes sense or of course means I can
have one or the other just having one is
sufficient okay
so just having one is enough
so it's either all or I can have both
okay not means well you get what that
means right I want to have this
condition and I'm excluding this one
okay in other words I want to mark to be
you know greater than something and I
definitely want to avoid something else
happening now like I said there are some
other ones as well and you know for
example you might hear about NAND okay
I'll let you look up that one in a
second not that common one that is
important though it's not as common as
these three but still relatively is
called X or that's quite an important
one and people get confuse that so let
me try to explain it okay
the X stands for exclusive
exclusive so you can see hmm it's
similar to it's in a little a or b but
what's the difference okay
exclusive means I could only have one or
the other right you can't have a and B
if you look at this one in here
A or B hmm that includes a and B I can
have both at the same time that's fine
okay but a X or B means you can have one
we can have the other but here both it
doesn't fulfill that condition okay now
like I said if you go look up logical
operators or boolean operators okay you
can find a few more of them but these
are the main ones
okay now one more little thing before
I'm going to give you an exercise one
cards what are wild cards are about
there are particular thing you can add
into your conditions that allow your
searches to be more flexible okay I'll
explain what I mean
this stuff is the first kind of wild
card what it means is any set of
characters okay for instance I might
want everyone in the class whose last
name whose surname starts with T okay I
don't know for instance maybe I'm
looking for a student and I remember
their surnames that's a T but I can't
remember what this zone actually is okay
so what I would search for the way I'll
use this query is at a student dot last
name okay and then I'd say it's equal to
t stop or t asterisk right by the way
all text conditions they have to be in
quote marks okay so it was a number I
wouldn't need quite marks but because
it's text I do so you can see this would
return things like it would return a Leo
tan or a Connie Tran because it meets
these conditions and it's any set right
so it can be you know a really really
long name off on here okay this can be
any number of characters right okay now
the second wild-card is a question mark
question mark like the asterisks but it
can only stand for one character okay
single unknown count
okay so for instance suppose I know I've
got a student and a certain age either
I don't know it either Chan or its gem
right but I don't know which one now it
will be a really bad idea for me to use
the first wildcard the asterisk right
this if I were at CH stop okay
I'm going to return far more results
than actually interest to you I won't
just return Chan and Chan I'll return
Chong and Chu and in a school I this is
a bad idea right it's going to go on and
on I'm so I could do this but it's very
inefficient better if I know it's that
specific right is to say student dot
last name is equal to quite see H these
are the letters I know question mark
there's the unknown right and I know it
ends in an N it ends in an M okay so
that will return just Chan and Chander
maybe H in I suppose or China yeah you
get the idea
okay so those are the wildcards now
let's come back here